Guys, welcome to module three, content is king.
And before we get going, I just want to talk about why content is the way that we win.
This is how we win is through content, okay?
And if you guys remember back to one of the videos I covered in module one of the technical
training, a part two of this whole digital landlords program, is content is one of the
big three things.
Content is one of the pieces of the 80-20 rule.
You can do a lot of things wrong, and if you do a couple of them right, you're going to
win.
And so the reason why content is so important, as I mentioned, if you think about it, Google
does not have millions of people that are just looking at websites and getting together
and saying, this one should rank, this one shouldn't, this one should, this one shouldn't.
They have an algorithm and they have bots that crawl, they crawl the websites.
And these bots, they can't see, they can read text.
And so it's interesting, people, like if you think about it, the only way Google can know
what your website is about is by what is on your website, what kind of text is on your
website.
And you go look at most of these websites for Tony, the tree care guy, or Jack, the
concrete guy, and they don't have any content.
They have 20 words, 30 words, 40 words, they don't know that it's important.
And on top of that, they don't want to do it because writing content is hard.
Writing content actually takes work.
Writing content requires you to use your head.
So the number one thing is why it's important and why this is how we're going to win is
because it is one of the big three things that matter with ranking.
That's number one.
Number two, other companies, other, especially these local business owners, they're not willing
to do it and they're not doing it.
If you guys have done your due diligence properly, going all the way back to looking for layups
in part one of Digital Landlords, you will notice that the people that you're competing
against are not big national companies.
These are little teeny mom and pop shops.
They probably went to GoDaddy, set up a little website, or went to WIC, set up a little website,
or paid their needs so that if you set up a little website, these guys are not going
to be hard to beat, but we have to beat them with content because if they have an old domain,
we can't beat that.
We can't fight it.
We can't fake our domain size or our domain age, sorry.
So content is super, super important because of those facts.
So guys, this is super important.
Instead of just moaning and groaning and saying, oh my gosh, I got to write the content, look
at it as this is how we're going to win.
And if we can get good at content, if we can get obsessed with content and getting good
at it and good enough that then we can outsource it and we can have our outsourcers and our
team and our virtual assistants write our content for us, this is how we're going to
win.
If we do the content correctly, we can avoid a lot of other stuff.
We can rank much more quickly.
We can avoid doing a lot of backlinks.
We can avoid a lot of things, okay?
And it's just like if you use the example of Kobe Bryant, right, I always talk about
Kobe.
Kobe was obsessed with the little things.
He was obsessed with the things that other players wouldn't get obsessed with.
He was obsessed with the angle he came off of the screen.
He was obsessed with the crossover.
He was obsessed with how he came out of a double team.
Equally, if we want to get to that level, if we want to grow our businesses and make
these more than just making a couple bucks here or a couple bucks there, we need to get
obsessed with these things.
And this is one of those things, if you take the time to learn it and you take the time
to get good at it, it will pay dividends for every single project.
Let's keep going.